[Music]
in slope split news celeb split split
split submitted by Steve's lips what
about Steve slips I don't know what they
look at mine I own them in my purse
Donald Trump Junior's wife has filed for
divorce she fell for dessert
I want some too if my husband was direct
you're very some chocolate
why'd she do that she said I'm not gonna
be with you anymore because you are so
mean if you if you know well that hunts
animals the trophy hunters oh no because
I mess around if you're not gonna eat
them up ugh I don't hunt nothing Donald
Trump jr. and Vanessa yeah I'm she
hottie about NASA Trump
she looks good yeah kids together - real
good
I just had one and I don't look like
that
so they recently announced that they're
getting divorced oh damn that's not a
good picture yeah
but why you have five kids 12 years five
kids yeah 12 years bye kids you can get
beat up so right now nothing's been like
confirmed confirmed but the gossip sites
are speculating they're like oh there's
a source that says yeah there's a source
that said that she's splitting up with
him because she's treated as a
second-rate citizen and that he puts her
on a allowance and that she even has to
ask money from her family like her mom
she had asked her mom for money and how
much does that allowance like fifty
thousand a month you would think that
that would be worked out in like the
like you know when you get married
you're you you talk about finances first
like if I stay home and take care of the
kids all day like I get X amount of
money spending money and stuff so the
gossip is she's not she doesn't get
enough money maybe she was working it
out and she's like alimony would pay way
more than this yeah very smart oh you
could buy a nanny with more with money
lot of kids doesn't that suck though
when the marriage becomes like a
business transaction yeah like it's IQ
but maybe it started as a business
transaction true did they marry for love
or did they marry for money I feel like
that's how if it started that way if it
ends that way I feel like but without
five kids though it seems like it's a
little bit more it's more of a family
now at that point because if it was more
business you'd be like wouldn't you yeah
why don't you want your kids to take
over the business yeah
so legacy goes on cuz I mean that's how
kingdoms happen yeah they used to
execute the Queen if she didn't make a
boy yeah
yeah King Henry yeah he all three of his
wives got and then he said you know what
I'm just gonna make my own church cuz I
want a divorce the ball sacks produce
which sex yep or this Marv's sperms they
tell you the X and the y uh-huh we just
have the eggs but then the Spartan goes
up and says I would be a girl yeah so
they're also speculating that apparently
Donald Trump jr. had an affair with this
lady named Aubrey O'Day
you know she is know which song they did
dark Lindsay Lohan she she got fat in
Italian yeah so apparently back in 2011
she's not fat
I just see I just see a wide hips and
legs yeah she just looks like an upside
down mob like she's so compared to what
she surprised you have such a high
self-esteem girl compared away with that
one every man comments she looks like
she she bathed in this [ __ ] mud yeah
and Blakeley won I got you yeah the clay
mud yeah so apparently they met during
Celebrity Apprentice and here's a photo
of them together oh yeah they look like
they have relationship your hair matches
the tie I can't imagine them [ __ ] me
need them I can't imagine a [ __ ]
period it's like I come out to them
[ __ ] you can yeah I feel like he's
wearing like matching PJ's one of those
dudes yeah the buttons I go all the way
it's like two different style yeah make
sure him just pulling his dick out of
the [ __ ] dick hole and that's it like
he'd take off his tiny kids his loafers
on
you has those socks and those [ __ ]
things that pull up the socks like a
male guard that he looks like though
that's American Psycho dude without the
chin though then without the sexy face
yeah yeah here's a week we could leave
it to Jake and use it to tear this dude
up yeah no no no jawline and you know
have a jawline matching pj wearing no
jawline mofo you have a very big hole
shut up you just got the lady fat she
was like she likes me she looks like she
likes to [ __ ] MMA fighters like that
kind of look she is another new fighter
she likes she likes guys that work at
the carnival
they're both blue-collar kind of guys
you know what I mean carnival yeah I
guess
well yeah like more like not that not
the trapeze guy okay yeah I was picture
kind of like flowery but they're more
white-collar yeah yeah not the gymnast
guy all the coaster engineers the
freakshow guys yeah yeah so either an M
an MMA fighter or a freak show guys yeah
that's the kind of guys you like a vault
has been rock star that too yeah I can
see that I see her with the hip hop guy
that that kind of - yeah you can go from
it could be building your son all the
way to hip hop guy
reality stars yeah yeah yeah aren't you
actually did data from jerseys that the
Jersey Shore called it I went yeah
Paulie she does look like she she could
do a Guido - yeah she looks very good
Snooki yeah she's a Snooki like a Star
Wars character yeah it doesn't match at
all that's like that's like a Old Navy
guy and then like like [ __ ] like a
straight-up hood rat yeah but like I
feel like when guys get super rich and
like in that zone of like richness like
they start like getting weird like their
freak side comes out and they start
liking tried everything yeah they like
want to try new different things yeah
that's what you always see like
politicians getting caught with like
transvestite hookers you know or
whatever not that that's like I'm just
saying like that's way different than
their wife where they could pull on
their wieners yeah they just want
something new like I want to milk some
dicks like an info maniac and he was
just going with like yeah everything do
you think that's what it is is that like
once they get money then they can just
let whatever was buried and suppress the
way down here they can select let it out
yeah I get it cuz they get everything
they want so that's like they want you
know the hottest of the hottest they
finally get her it's like MA now what
yeah it's going dog to try to [ __ ]
National Geographic girls with the
titties hanging down to their [ __ ]
kneecaps and [ __ ] yeah yeah so
everyone's just making fun of this whole
situation cuz it's like oh how funny
like she's divorcing the dude for being
so cheap what if Donald Trump is like
this like mastermind controller and he
like arranges all the marriages he makes
everybody through him so he probably
arranges all this [ __ ] and the kids just
have to follow cuz i watch this
documentary about the dot the donald
trump's dad and how he was super
controlling and he made everything like
he orchestrated everything like a
mastermind huh
feel like you're partly talking about it
and you're partly like fantasizing about
how you could be the twinkle in his eye
I bet he's a mastermind a few arranges
that like his foreplay
the other day I was kind of like jealous
because I saw Kim jong-un and Kim
jong-il he saw both of them one of them
said documentary and then I was thinking
like how similar it is to Donald Trump
were they all had really rich daddies no
powerful daddies that kind of set them
up right and I'm like I wish I I think
built like they built them up a certain
way during childhood yeah yeah you know
I don't know if I want to control them
like that but then I would like to be
controlled like that that would be nice
be controlled I mean like you don't seem
like the kind of guy that would [ __ ] I
mean look at me whether right like if it
got me to a certain point didn't ya
Mayweather's like the greatest but you
think he did that no it's his uncles his
dad so you want to be programmed hmm no
he doesn't
did it from the start they did it like a
baby too late for you then my dad tried
with music but he didn't even accomplish
my he's like hypnotizing his baby but I
don't want to do it to my kids I just
wanna I just wish like my grandpa was
like a king or something and then like
my dad was a king and then like me yeah
maybe now why don't you pick a different
life than when you were reincarnate why
did I choose this one
I don't know Allah I know stupid Saul
choices man
[Music]